[Music]
90 day fiance star
angela dean shocks fans by showing off
her new look
after dropping a serious amount of
weight
how many pounds have you lost now i've
lost a hundred
wow how do you feel how has your life
changed well i have more energy
the 55 year old reality star shared this
selfie to instagram
heading off to dinner in las vegas to
celebrate nick hogan's birthday
here's angela rocking a white halter top
pink hoops
natural makeup and a taut high ponytail
i feel you know i've always been
confident but i'm more confident
now than ever angela's fellow 90 day
fiance stars showed her a lot of love in
the comments
binium posted a series of emojis so did
darcy
and courtney simply wrote full glam
i was so happy angela also shared this
snap from the night with hogan's
girlfriend
tana leah who posted a series of snaps
from their celebration
check out angela showing off her new
look in a crisp white jumpsuit
they also posed for photos with another
90 day fiance star
debbie johnson and tana posted this pic
of angela
still looking great while lounging on
the floor thank you
for the bother my heart 90 day fiance
cameras have followed angela's journey
with her now husband
32 year old michael from nigeria through
multiple seasons of the show
longtime viewers agree angela's
transformation
is truly stunning i pronounced it to
appear as husband and wife mr
messy is kind of my kelly let's make
congratulations
the current season of 90 day fiance
happily ever after has documented
angela's entire weight loss
journey which also included a breast
reduction
oh my that's it that's all that's all
she wrote
mike mike is in nigeria
he's in lagos i don't like that
when angela spoke with e.t in april she
revealed that her hubby
wasn't exactly thrilled with her breast
reduction decision
i did my boobs and you know he loved my
boobs right
i i don't know if it was just him you
know not being a part of it because he's
over there
you know at the time or what but
we went through it like i mean i
literally
the grandkids was my main support and
for anyone considering taking a weight
loss journey of their own
angela offers this advice this ain't a
miracle surgery
it's it'll get you started but you have
to
do the work do the lifestyle change with
it
because this doesn't mean you can't gain
your weight back a couple years later
you can
you have to really all the effort you
put in and all the the
healing process if you get that far
you might as well stay on the cycle of
lifestyle change and you don't want to
go back and have to do this again
right because it is a journey yeah
it's a rainbow at the end of it i'm
telling you i've never felt so much
better in my life